Working together, they can paint the room in 12 7ths hours time. Great thinking
if you found this fraction. 12 7ths is equal to 1 hour and 5 7ths of an hour.
If we do some conversion and convert this to minutes, it's about one hour and
43 minutes. And here's the equation we want to set up. We know that Tim can
paint the room in 4 hours time. So he can complete one job in 4 hours. The
other way of thinking about this is that he will complete 1 4th of the job in 1
hour. Vanessa's painted the room in 3 hours. Which means she can complete the
full job in 3 hours time, job per hours. So, notice that we can think about
this as a rate. We have Tim completing 1 job in 4 hours and Vanessa completing
that same job in 3 hours. So if we add their two rates together, we would get
them completing the job in x hours time, the time you want to find. And now
here's the other way we were thinking about it. Tim can complete 1 4th of the
job in 1 hours time. Vanessa can complete 1 3rd of the job in 1 hours time. So
together they can complete 1 over x of the job in 1 hour's time. We start
solving this equation by multiplying though by the LCD. The least common
denominator is 4 times 3 times x. Or 12 x. We multiply each fraction by this
number, and that gives us 3 x here, 4 x here, and 12 here. We add our like
terms on the left to get 7 x equals 12. And finally we divide by 7 to get 1 x
is equal to 12 7ths. This is the amount of time it takes them to paint the room
together.